[Musique]
rempl
qu'est devenu le nautilus at il résisté
aux étreintes du maelström le capitaine
nemo est il toujours en vie poursuit-il
sous l'océan c'est effrayante
représailles les flots apporteront ils
un jour ce manuscrit qui renferme toute
l'histoire de sa vie soit réjean fans
honey 2 7e
presque tout ce qui est réalisé
aujourd'hui sous les mers grâce à la
technologie sous marine a été imaginé
par jules verne porcine alors pour moi
ce livre est comme un guide pour
l'avenir quand le capitaine nemo parle
des villes sous marine du futur
je m'identifie beaucoup à lui parce que
je pense aussi au plus profond de moi
qu'un jour nous verrons des villes sous
les mers
[Musique]
sur la côte ouest du canada dans la
province de colombie britannique
il existe un homme qui ne s'est jamais
remis de ses lectures d'enfance
rené théophile nuytten perpétue à sa
manière les aventures incroyables du
commandant du nautilus le capitaine nemo
des gratte ciels plantés sur l'océan
pacifique c'est ici à vancouver à deux
pas des chantiers navals de la ville que
phil nuytten a pris le commandement
d'une entreprise hors du commun il ya
plus de 40 ans le jeune plongeur s'est
fait une promesse il voulait à tout prix
déceler les énigmes d'un monde
sous-marin inconnue l'homme a dédié
toute sa vie et surtout son métier à la
découverte des profondeurs abyssales
parler mais le corps est un modèle
technique vieux de plusieurs millénaires
il est très ancien très primitif et
c'est pour cela que la technique est
comme une armure qui nous autorise à
aller où l'on ne pourrait jamais allé
avec notre enveloppe corporelle ringarde
alors mon boulot c'est de fabriquer des
machines des engins pour aller au fond
de tous les océans
peu à peu et à quelques détails près
phil nuytten s'est construit un monde
identique à celui de son héros vernien
de vingt mille lieues sous les mers
ce marin reclus dans les abysses est
protégé par l'épaisse cuirasse de son
hôte et du sein
[Musique]
il
c'est un mélangeur d'oxygène je les
fabrique et quand j'avais 12 ou 13 ans à
l'intérieur il y a une petite boîte en
métal pour respirer l'oxygène se trouve
ici et pour l'envoyer il suffit de faire
cela inspiration expiration
voilà tout se faisait à la main et ça
marchait bien
avec cet appareil je pouvais rester 40
minutes sous l'eau enfin de 30 à 40
minutes
je voulais construire quelque chose de
nouveau qui pouvait me permettre de
rester en bas c'est pour cela que j'ai
écrit ici même si j'étais très jeune
expérimental ce site le sm en fait ne
veut rien dire
machine d'urgence sous marine mais ça
avait l'air tellement bien tellement
cool et six scientifiques nous allons de
découverte en découverte
petit à petit fils nous explique sa
manière de concevoir ses inventions
il nous livre même quelques secrets de
fabrication
ne vous inquiétez pas ça c'est du
polycarbonate et ça ne cassera pas c'est
très solide et alors je compte mettre
une membrane ici et cela va s'ouvrir et
se fermer comme un parent à pied lorsque
vous nagez vous faites cela vers le bas
jusqu'ici ça s'ouvre puis quand vous
remontez cela se ferment faire fermer
etc
ça c'est le produit auquel je réfléchis
maintenant c'est vraiment le tout
premier essai histoire de constater si
cette idée va marcher
ensuite je fabriquerai le prochain
modèle avec des matériaux plus doux sans
lévis et tout le reste
avec ça j'espère inventé une palme qui
sera très large coup de pied vers le bas
est très étroite lorsque le pire au mic
les ateliers de phil nuytten ont des
airs de capharnaüm
ici et là sont entassés des centaines de
souvenirs des restes d'exploration ou
encore quelques anciens trophée sous
marins c'est un véritable musée qui
s'ouvrent ou les pièces de haute
technologies côtoient la préhistoire de
la plongée sous marine
voici l'aquarius un sous marin pour
trois personnes
il a ébloui mance le pilote ça soit au
fond et comment de l'engin avec l'aide
des deux caméras on utilise beaucoup
pour des travaux de surveillance pour le
département des pêches les pompes les
quais le passage des câbles sous marins
et de pit lane
c'est un sous-marin idéal parce qu'on
peut transporter beaucoup d'équipements
à l'intérieur et ils te restait sous
l'eau de longue période
tous ces sous marins ont au moins trois
jours d'autonomie sous la mer alors en
cas d'urgence nous pouvons rester
immergé pendant trois jours une maison
général on reste 6 au 8 heures sous
l'eau ce sous-marin là s'appelle la
loutres de mer
on l'a fabriqué ici en 1971 il a fait
tellement de plongée mais on avait
toujours un problème avec la petitesse
des hublots
si vous vous écartez d'hublot alors
votre champ visuel rétrécie à l'époque
qu'il fallait être très très près pour
voir quelque chose
[Musique]
des machines incroyable il y en a
partout il y en a dedans mais il y en a
aussi dehors
d'une pièce à l'autre on découvre des
bathyscaphes aux formes bizarres fils
collectionne aussi de drôles de masques
de plongée
c'est amusant parce que lorsque l'on
entre ici et on voit des time ans de
vieilleries inutile il y en a qui disent
que tout ce foutoir ressemble à
l'intérieur de ma tête parce que toutes
ces vieilles choses se mélange avec les
nouvelles je garde tout cela pour en
abuser
parce que je crois que pour avancer dans
la vie et connaître son chemin il faut
savoir d'où l'on vient
[Musique]
lorsqu'il est enfant phil nuytten
apprend à nager dans les eaux profondes
de colombie britannique
à peine adolescent il devient un
chasseur sous marin hors pair
[Musique]
plus tard le jeune canadien tient une
petite boutique de matériel de plongée à
vancouver il a 15 ans alors
[Musique]
avec sa bande de copains il plonge dès
qu'ils le peuvent pour aller débusquer
des pieuvres géantes et autres monstres
marins qu'ils revendent ensuite aux
aquariums de la ville de vancouver
[Musique]
ils n'ont alors que de vieilles
combinaisons de caoutchouc leur
équipement le sommaire mais leur chasse
est souvent miraculeuse le combat du
capitaine nemo contre un calamar géant
c'est encore une histoire qui hantent
les pensées du jeune fils
[Musique]
à l'époque le garçon a une spécialité
qui lui fait prendre des risques
importants
il compte parmi les meilleurs lorsqu'il
s'agit de se mesurer en apnée pour
longer à plus de 20 mètres de profondeur
il est le meilleur jusqu'à ce jour où en
pleine compétition
il reste au fond complètement inanimé
[Musique]
il ya deux choses que j'ai apprises tu
fait d'être inconscient sous l'eau la
première c'est qu'on entend souvent que
votre vie défile devant vous alors que
vous êtes en train de vous noyer et
l'autre c'est que c'est vraiment
terrible de mourir noyés parce qu'on est
tous on s'étrangle ces deux choses dans
mon cas était complètement fausse j'ai
retenu mon souffle le plus longtemps
possible lors de cette compétition
d'apnée en eaux profondes
j'ai pensé qu en relâchant du co2 je
pourrais rejoindre la surface mais c'est
que j'ai expiré j'ai inspiré de l'eau
dans mes poumons
c'est la sensation
c'était un incroyable soulagement de
l'eau froide descendait dans ma poitrine
avant je brûlais à l'intérieur pour
pouvoir respirer et là je me suis senti
très lourd alors que j'essayais de
remonter le long du film je me sentais
si lourd avec toute cette eau est si peu
d'air je parle mais et palmer encore
mais je me voyais lentement glisser vers
le bas
gwendal
ce jour là si fils n'avait pas laisser
l'eau de mer remplir ses poumons
il serait bel et bien mort
[Musique]
mais cette expérience traumatisante n'a
fait que renforcer son envie de défier
les profondeurs et depuis il n'a cessé
de repousser les limites du corps humain
grâce à ses inventions
il est devenu l'un des pionniers en
matière de plongée dans des conditions
extrêmes dans les années 80 il est avec
des équipes de scientifiques canadiens
le premier à tenter une descente sous
les glaces de l'arctique
[Musique]
lorsque vous êtes assis au bord du trou
fait dans la glace et que vous sentez
vous au travers d'une nouvel équipement
que vous avez fabriqué la plus grande
peur c'est que cela ne marche pas le
fait de se mettre sous l'eau et essayer
de respirer de nager et de voir que cela
marche comme vous l'aviez prévu
la sensation de libération voire
d'euphorie et complètement larrieu
ensuite seulement vous constatez que
l'on est vraiment très froides qu elle
s'insinue dans votre combinaison et or
je pouvais sentir comme une petite
rivière de chaleur sur mon bras et bien
que je suis au chaud et bien je sais que
dehors c'est glacial
c'est un peu comme si vous étiez dans un
réfrigérateur et que le froid ne vous
avait pas encore atteint mais vous
pouvez sentir que le froid est bien là
mon
ouais mais mon plus beau souvenir de
cette époque c'est que c'était vraiment
un endroit étrange comme un autre monde
tous les que glacé neige droit une fois
dans l'eau je ne me souviens que d'une
chose je suis si heureux que mon
matériel fonctionne si bien
[Musique]
affranchi des pesanteurs terrestre le
sombre capitaine nemo chercher la vérité
et la liberté dans les profondeurs film
nuytten lui puise son inspiration auprès
d'un peuple lié corps et âme à l'océan
il ya une trentaine d'années fils est
adopté par l'une des nombreuses tribus
indiennes de colombie britannique
[Musique]
les indiens kwakwa la vivent ici depuis
des milliers d'années grâce aux
richesses incroyables des eaux du
détroit de johnson ils sont reconnus
dans la région comme les meilleurs
sculpteurs de totems et de masques
rituels
issu d'une famille métis de l'intérieur
des terres canadiennes fils renoue ici
avec une longue tradition de temps à
autre ils aiment revenir sur l'île aux
cormorans une île isolée au beau milieu
d'un bras de mer au nord-est de l'île de
vancouver
je suis venu ici quand j'étais très
jeune pour chercher des informations sur
le peuple quoique et à ma grande
surprise bien des années plus tard je
suis revenu ici pour plonger parce que
cette île a des réserves très limité en
eau douce
en fait nous est acheminé jusqu'ici de
l'île de vancouver grâce à un eye liner
alors avec l'un d'eux très bon plongeur
professionnel de cette île un gars
innommé barrington
on avait l'habitude de surveiller ce
type-là une fois par an et je suis venu
ici encore et encore c'était à chaque
fois l'occasion de renouer des liens
avec les enfants que j'avais connu quand
j'étais petit lob
comme mon frère l'a rencontré il a été
très impressionné par phil ces deux là
je vais pas vous raconter tout ce qu'ils
faisaient mais il était vraiment très
bon ami et c'est mon frère qui a pensé à
l'adopter il m'a téléphoné
on a organisé une grande cérémonie dans
la maison des anciens
je suis très fier très heureux de
l'avoir comme soeur watts et 16 lors de
cette adoption
voilà ce que la famille nous prenons la
responsabilité de cette offre
cet homme nous appartient désormais et
nous prenons donc toutes les
responsabilités pour ses actes sa
conduite etc
ça c'est un engagement très important
pour cette famille ils ne font cela que
s'ils pensent que c'est bénéfique pour
leur communauté
c'est donc un rituel fondamental dans
cette culture
le capitaine nemo prenait fait et cause
pour un jeune indien pêcheurs de perles
fines mitaine quant à lui se bat pour
que les anciennes oeuvres d'art
confisquée aux indiens puis dispersés de
par le monde revienne sur l'île aux
cormorans
[Musique]
la culture de ce peuple est à la fois si
simple celle-ci complexe pour moi c'est
une véritable analogie avec toutes les
missions sous marine que nous faisons de
par le monde
souvent quand je suis saoul ou je pense
aux cérémonies traditionnelles des potes
lâchent leurs chambres les danses
indiennes
c'est étonnant comme tout cela prend du
sens dans un endroit comme celui-ci
[Musique]
après ce voyage initiatique est une
plongée au coeur de l'imaginaire de
notre nemo des temps modernes
nous rentrons à vancouver
[Musique]
et
c'est ici dans ces ateliers que fils met
au point la plupart des engins consacré
aux travaux sous marins son équipage
d'ingénieurs est composé d'anciens
plongeurs ou scaphandrier professionnel
aujourd'hui fils est devenu un business
man redoutable jeff son bras droit on
sait quelque chose
le jeune pilote de sous marins est l'un
des rares à partager les prouesses
techniques de ces machines digne d'un
roman de science fiction quand il nous
présente un dessin en général ma
réaction c'est la peur je ne dis pas ça
pour faire du mauvais esprit cela parce
que je sais qu'il a pensé tel ou tel
véhicule dans sa tête il a mis sur le
papier avait donc nous donner la mission
de le construire et je sais qu'ils ne
nous lâchera pas d'un pouce avant que sa
nouvelle invention ne devienne réalité
on nous a toujours appris que l'une des
choses qui distingue l'homme de l'animal
et cette opposition entre notre poussée
des autres doigts c'est pas vrai car si
c'était vrai et que seul ce mouvement
était nécessaire alors les homards les
crabes dirige le monde
en fait ce qui est utile ça n'est pas
uniquement ce mouvement là mais aussi et
surtout celui là
pour phil c'est donc l'observation et
surtout l'instinct qui prime
on highway regarder quand je sers et si
je peux ressentir la texture et la forme
exactement comme si je ne faisais avec
mes propres lois tout ce que je fais
avec ma main est relié ici avec deux
petites qui choisit
[Musique]
après avoir frôlé la mort sous l'eau
après avoir vu disparaître ses
compagnons de plonger lors d' accidents
de décompression
l'ancien scaphandrier n'a de cesse
d'inventer d'étranges véhicules
subaquatique
[Musique]
pour aller toujours plus loin et
toujours plus profond sans cette
angoisse de l'accident fils invente des
combinaison futuriste
des robots téléguidés de véritable
vaisseau denner autant d'outils pour la
recherche scientifique
les travaux sous marins ou encore la
découverte de cet univers passionnant
que sont les entrailles de l'océan
[Musique]
lorsque je revis le temps passé à bord
du nautilus
tous ces événements heureux ou
malheureux depuis ma disparition de la
brame lincoln saab le sous marin en
chasse les papous et les sauvages
le cimetière de corail le tunnel de
suèvres les il centre à l'appel de vigo
l'atlantis le banc de glace le pôle sud
et l'emprisonnement dans les glaces la
bataille contre la pioche les tempêtes
du gulf stream et le reboot scène de ce
bateau coulé avec son équipage
ces événements passe au travers de ma
tête comme le décor dintilhac et le
capitaine nemo apparaître
disproportionné il n'était plus comme
moi un homme mais un génie de la mer
[Musique]
nemo parcours est sans relâche le monde
invisible des mères l'insatiable fils
compte lui aussi grâce à ses inventions
géniales laisser son nom gravé dans les
pages de l'histoire des abysses
ce matin fils et son équipage de
plongeurs qui de vancouver en direction
des montagnes du nord cette fois
l'expédition sera courte
avec le mauvais temps ils n'auront que
deux jours pour tester les capacités
d'un nouveau sous marin de poche le dit
walker
ce qui est intéressant dans cet endroit
c'est de voir que les abysses de l'océan
pacifique sont si proches de grands
coureurs à l'instant précis il y à trois
cents mètres de profondeur alors que
nous ne sommes pas très éloigné du
rivage
toutes ces îles qui sortent de la mer
comme des montagnes
j'ai vécu ici tu es ma vie et je ne me
lasse pas de regarder tout cela c'est
mais fascinant de trouver des endroits
où la civilisation et le monde sauvage
sont si rapprochées c'est magnifique
le capitaine nemo commandait le nautilus
fils lui se contente d'un minuscule
sous-marin qui l'a surnommé le
travailleur des profondeurs c'est le
dernier né de sa flotte sous marine
et c'est encore une fois une avancée
incroyable pour le monde de la plongée
et la découverte des abysses océanique
[Musique]
l'aquarius d'un côté et le dit power
coeur de l'autre unique en son genre
phil orchestre la manoeuvre tel un
pilote de chasse avant des exercices en
vol ses opérations en mer sont très
délicates aux commandes du dip marqueur
une fois sous l'eau ses robes qui va
mener la danse fils sera à quelques
mètres de lui quand il commencera ses
manoeuvres
c'est vrai que quelquefois ça devient un
peu effrayant mais il suffit de mettre
un peu d'ordre dans son esprit pour se
rendre compte qu'une fois en bas il n'y
a rien qui pourrait vous faire du mal on
peut pas être claustrophobe
car vous pouvez constater qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de place là-dedans le plus
étonnant c'est qu'une fois ferme et une
faute êtes assis depuis 15 à 20 minutes
alors vous vous sentez rétrécir alors
que l'espace lui s'agrandit ouais c'est
vraiment la chose la plus étonnante
je ne peux pas expliquer comment et
pourquoi cela se produit mais d'un seul
coup tout devient assez grands lacs dont
[Musique]
nous arrivons de 600
c'est un passage étroit un genre de
fjords et maintenant nous arrivons dans
cette petite là où il ya la flèche rouge
se trouver l'épave qu'on appelle la
chaudière c'est une épave superbe
nous allons mouillé par ici parce que
cette épave représente une plateforme
idéale pour stationner nos sous marins
avant les tests et le fait de nous
trouver juste au dessus des fonds nous
évite de soulever la vase nous pouvons
obtenir des photographies parfaite de
ces essais
[Musique]
c'est l'équivalent
et vous
[Musique]
la fifa
neuf trous va essayer de passer
[Musique]
sochaux il ya quelque chose
d'incroyablement gratifiant lorsque
l'eau vous recouvre la tête
fermez les yeux vous regardez autour et
là vous vous dites est ce un arrachement
je suis vivant à ce moment là vous avez
le sentiment d'avoir construit de vos
mains un engin qui vous permet d'aller
sous l'eau c'est un test immédiat sans
appel il n'y a pas de théorie pour cela
une fois que vous êtes en dessous soit
ça marche
soit ça ne marche pas
[Musique]
installé dans l'aquarium fils et jeff
part à la rencontre du 10 points au
coeur
[Musique]
ils commencent leur lente descente à la
recherche d'un bâtiment militaire datant
de la seconde guerre mondiale
[Musique]
je
ici l'aquarius négative je n'ai pas
encore l'épave en vue pour l'instant
terminée ça y est on n'allait pas droit
devant nous
[Musique]
le navire est couché sur son flanc on
distingue à peine ses canons et sa
cheminée
[Musique]
quand soudain deux petites lueurs
apparaissent derrière la coque rouillée
[Musique]
et spiritueux du fourrage sera violent
et horrible
sassou mara qui vole ses cibles
tu peux commencer des essais de
manipulation
[Musique]
le zoo
le
[Musique]
on
regardez quand je suis allongé dans ce
sous marin je n'ai rien sur le visage
rien dans la bouche c'est comme si
j'étais à la surface alors dans ces
moments le rêve d'une ville subaquatique
c'est à dire un lieu où on pourrait
vivre et travailler ce rêve devient réel
cela relève bien sûr de la science
fiction mais ici ils font de la mer dans
ce sous marin avec le deep water à
l'extérieur qui stationnent sur le pont
du l'épave
soudainement il ne me semble plus que
cela soit ainsi qu'envers d'une si
grande étape à franchir
peut-être que cela arrivera bien plus
tôt qu'on ne le pense
[Musique]
vivre sous la mer comme sur terre voici
le grand rêve de file
les cinéastes font d'ailleurs souvent
appel à lui pour dessiner concevoir les
costumes ou les machines infernales de
leur aventure sous-marine ses rêves de
gamins prennent à leur vie comme dans le
film abyss une superproduction de james
cameron
[Musique]
je me demande souvent qu aurait pensé le
capitaine nemo de tout cela mais plus
important encore qu'aurait donné jules
verne pour être dans la position où je
me trouve actuellement être là au fond
de l'océan et regarder à travers cette
grande bulle c'est tout de même un décor
qui l'a vu uniquement dans son
imagination
alors voir ces choses qu'il a vues dans
son esprit les voir pour de vrai
j'imagine qu'il aurait donné n'importe
quoi pour voir ça
qui
[Musique]
avec toutes ces inventions fils a fait
fortune sur le marché des engins sous
marins
le petit dit power coeur intéresse de
plus en plus certains milliardaires en
mal de sensations qui veulent faire de
la plongée sous-marine en eaux profondes
un nouveau loisir
en attendant que des villes tout entière
surgissent dans l'obscurité des océans
il est grand temps que fils rentre à
vancouver afin de poursuivre ses
recherches interminables
c'est
[Musique]
dans les bassins du centre d'essai
maritime de la ville il tente de mettre
au point depuis près de dix ans un
scaphandre révolutionnaire une
combinaison capable de transporter un
homme à plus de 300 mètres sous la mer
dans un confort presque parfait
[Musique]
après la conquête de l'espace la guerre
des profondeurs fils travaillent sans
relâche parce qu'il sait qu'un jour les
fonds marins deviendront un enjeu
économique colossal et ce jour là il
compte bien être en première ligne 1
[Musique]
il y a toujours des situations où on a
l'impression que le mauvais sort
s'acharne sur vous mais si vous arrivez
ne serait ce qu'une seule fois à faire
marcher votre invention alors le système
fonctionnera ce matin on a vu une nage
parfaite à lens était bon avec une seule
l'âge réussi on sait que cela pourra se
faire une nouvelle fois c'est un peu
comme des canards qui nous pensent les
doigts c'est très difficile de faire mal
à quelqu'un de cette manière mais plus
tard ils finissent par vous mangez tout
entier
le scaphandre ultra moderne n'est pas
encore sur le marché
et déjà il attire toutes les attentions
et notamment c'est le militaire
[Applaudissements]
cette nouvelle combinaison va tout
changer pour les plongeurs militaires
ils ne seront plus instables de la
pression de la décompression
ils pourront rester sous l'eau pendant
de très longues périodes par exemple ils
pourront quitter un sous marin nucléaire
se rendre discrètement jusqu'au rivage
avec un petit moyen de propulsion
il y a quelques années de cela nous
avons rencontré pas mal de mercenaires
des soldats de fortune
je leur ai demandé pourquoi est-ce que
vous portez autant d'intérêt à posséder
cette combinaison pour une ou deux
personnes
et pourquoi pas pour tout un régiment
ils m'ont répondu il suffit d'avoir une
ou deux personnes bien équipée au coeur
de la bataille et c'est gagné
nle
[Musique]
en attendant de futurs conflits sous
marins la nuit tombe sur vancouver
et lorsque les affaires se font trop
pressante fils a parfois besoin de
retrouver son univers imaginaire quand
il n'est pas sous la mer il s'échappe
dans un petit atelier secret situé juste
à côté de sa maison
lorsqu'il a été adopté par les indiens
de l'île aux cormorans
les chefs du clan lui en donner un droit
un genre d'héritage dont il doit prendre
le plus grand soin c'est à lui que
revient la charge de sculpter des totems
des masques ou encore des bijoux pour
les cérémonies traditionnelles
ils lui ont même donné le nom d'un grand
poisson en guise de totem le red snapper
de ce stade b dans la tradition des
indiens quoi comme on pense que c'est le
roi du monde sous marin
la raison c'est que la couleur ce
poisson sous l'eau et comme le cuivre et
tout le poisson sera recouvert de cuivre
de cette couleur là chez les colts la
personne qui possède le plus de cuivre
comme par exemple ces plaques rituel est
considéré comme l'homme le plus riche
village alors par extrapolation
ils disent qu'un poisson recouvert de
cuivre doit être le roi du monde sous
marin et figurez vous que mon nom
traditionnel et klaxons ce qui signifie
watts n'a peur mais
[Musique]
cela travail
il peut penser que c'est un primitif
cette discipline très rigide qui remonte
à des milliers d'années est très
différente des technologies sous-marines
dernier cri et pour moi c'est deux
choses se rejoignent complètement parce
que lorsque je sculpte je me surprends à
rêver à des créatures sous-marines fait
chuter signe alors un poisson un aigle
marin et je pense à eux sulu et puis
parfois lorsque je suis dans mes sous
marin et que j'attends par exemple qu'on
veuille bien toucher la grille avant de
descendre
eh bien je pense à la danse je pense à
mes masques ou je ne sais quoi encore
il y a longtemps les indiens croyait
qu'à monde subaquatique existait un
monde semblable à notre monde en surface
il pensait aussi que chaque animal et
chaque être humain possède un double
soulier il croyait aussi que les fonds
des mers était la demeure des noyers et
par exemple lorsque l'un d'eux se noyait
ils pensaient qu'ils allaient vivre une
nouvelle vie sous l'eau
où
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et de temps en temps c'est vrai qu'il
est si pris par les choses qu'il fait il
ne se rend plus compte de ce qui se
passe autour d'alice mais c'est
peut-être là tout le secret de sa
réussite
moi je m'occupe des choses du quotidien
pour le laisser non seulement rêver mais
aussi explorer et
et faire aboutir ces projets on peut
dire effectivement qu'il ne vit pas tout
à fait sûr notre
[Musique]
à défaut de vivre sous l'eau filet
mairie sa femme s'envole vers une petite
île boisée située à 20 minutes de leur
maison de vancouver c'est le refuge
familiale loin des bruits de l'atelier
et des grands projets sous-marins
[Musique]
à l'image de nemo le commandant de
nautilus notre inventeur s'est trouvé
une île mystérieuse un endroit retiré du
monde
[Musique]
je relis ce livre et toutes les
aventures étrange du nautilus du
personnage conseil du canadian aide et
bien sûr de nemo de son équipage
je ne peux m'empêcher de penser à ma
propre aventure autour du monde
tout s'est plongé un peu partout dans
l'arctique canadien sous les glaces
jusqu'au golfe du mexique de la côte
pacifique d'amérique du nord aux côtes
de l'atlantique la france de la
méditerranée des plongées aux fidji à
tahiti en australie les gens me
demandent souvent mais quel est votre
endroit préféré bien là je dois admettre
comme lieux préférés a toujours été ici
en colombie britannique
sur cette île de galliano qui est pour
moi le plus bel endroit du monde à mons
b d'infopresse
[Musique]
tout au long de ce voyage dans
l'imaginaire de phil nuytten en relisant
avec lui toutes ces aventures
sous-marines en plongeant à bord de ces
engins du futur nous avons acquis une
certitude
l'esprit du capitaine nemo est bel et
bien vivant il n'avait quelque part au
large des côtes de colombie britannique
[Musique]
on